(electronic music)
- It's now it's time for
tonight's hashtag wars.
(audience cheers)
- Moshe.
- Brad (bleeps) and Angelina Dookie.
- Yeah, good, points.
Nice, points, Jesse.
- Dissentary Bradshaw.
- Yeah, OK, good, points.
Moshe.
- Bradley Pooper, Crap Galafanakis,
and Diarrhea Helms in Hangover Poop.
- Wow!
I'm gonna give you 200 points for that.
Oh, Jesse.
- Is my (bleep) working, man?
- [Chris] No, you've gotta
have your hand on the buzzer.
- You have to hit the button.
- I hit the (bleep) twice, man!
- [Chris] Jesse.
- I've never felt like I
was gonna get punched more.
John Mexican Tap Waters.
- (laughing) Points, Donell.
- For the black people, Dr.
Reverend Shartin Luther King.
- Wow, points.
Moshe.
- Taylor Swiftly get me home,
I'm about to (bleep) my pants.
- Yeah, points, Jesse.
- Edward James Almost (bleep) Myself.
- [Chris] Yeah, points.
Yes, Rob Huebel.
- Atlas Shrugged and
Then Pooped Everywhere.
- (laughing) Points, Owen.
- Superfudge.
- Points, yes, Huebel.
- Diarrhea-Netics.
- OK (audience cheers).
Points, Riggle.
- A Tale of Two (bleep).
- Yes, excellent, points.
Owen.
- The Heartbreaking Dump
of Staggering Gyros.
Written by David Smells Like Eggers.
- OK, good, points,
very literary for this
crowd, but excellent,
I'll give you points anyway, Riggle.
- All Quiet on the Western Grunt.
- Points, Rob.
- To Kill a Mockingturd.
- Yes, points, Riggle.
- Lord of the Flies Around
the Dump I Just Took.
- Yes, points.
I like that there was one
lord of all those flies.
Minions, gather 'round.
Yes, Rob.
- Me (bleep) Pretty One Day.
- [Chris] Yes, Kurt.
- Turn down for plop.
- Points, nice, Jason.
- Oh, the places you'll go.
- Oh, nice, that's adorable, points.
Jessimae.
- Our father who shart in Heaven.
- Nice, points, a very
famous quote, points.
Kurt.
- We're gonna need a bigger butt.
- Jason.
- (bleep) happens.
- Yes, points.
I mean, it's right there,
it was right there.
That was from the movie Forrest Dump.
- Forrest Dump.
- Points, Jason.
- To (bleep) or not to, uh, too late.
(audience laughs)
- Jessimae.
- Show me the runny.
- Nice, Kurt.
- That's not a knife,
you (bleep) in your hand.
- [Chris] Yes, Steve Agee.
- Slip 'N (bleep) N' Slide.
- Yes (laughs), points.
- Megan.
- Plop-It.
- Yeah, good, points.
Doug.
- Speak 'N Smell.
- Yeah, points.
Yes, Megan.
- Silly Poopy.
- Yeah, you can mash
it onto a comic strip.
I'll give you that,
points, yeah, I like that.
Doug.
- Lower GI Joe.
- Oh, so good.
And you know what comes out?
Cobra!
Points to Doug, Steve.
- Hot Steaming Wheels.
- (laughing) Points, God damn it, Doug.
- Paddington Bear (bleep) in the Woods.
And will (bleep) you up.
- And will (bleep), points.
Nice points, Megan.
- Sharts Against Humanity.
- Yes, excellent, points, nice.
Megan.
- Strawberry Shartcake.
- Yes, good, points.
And her hair smells like?
- Sharts.
Yeah, OK, good, points.
Steve.
- And strawberries!
- [Steve] Rainbow (bleep).